hey film courage my name is free cobra
errands I'm 18 years old and yeah let's
jump into it this is a response to your
open call for screenwriters and no
introduction um I'm my name is free go
Bradley errands or just Freegal errands
um I'm 18 I've been writing for a large
sum of my life and I'm only I've only
seen 18 years but i guess you can see
like 11 years I've been writing and when
I say writing I mean like you know like
what I do now I guess like I still write
stories and stuff um I've been writing a
book since I was like
14 and you know that sets going same
pace so I was 14 but I believe my style
is getting more like I feel like I'm
ready to be heard is what i can say so
let's jump into it EEE
how long have you been a screenwriter
I've been a screenwriter for a few
months honestly um I started back in
November I've been writing free
screenplay so far all together I mean
like I you know I'll do some no stop and
the next day I'll work on the other and
then like a couple days ago i started a
third one so we'll see how that works
out but yeah
how long have you been working on your
current script well the longest grouped
I've been working on I've been working
on since December so three months yeah
like three months and I'm fairly far
into it um yeah next question
why did you write it um okay fair enough
when I was in high school I suffered
with on depression it was on it was
really bad um I don't know like I guess
it was just puberty but like just
something about like that specific year
of high school my senior year was like I
don't know why but I just I just felt so
depressed and like outcasts and i still
had I feel like I still had the demons
in well not demons but I like I still
carry demons with me and I just like
started writing this story and I like it
was it felt great you know like I i felt
like i was like letting loose of
something that I've been keeping my deep
inside of me for a long time and I just
kept working on that story working on
that story until my teacher mr. Warren
he was like a mentor to me told me you
know he thinks I should write it into
his creeply and I've always wanted to be
a screenwriter it's just like I've also
you know I also wanted to play as a
novel so I'm never too
sure which media I'm going to take a
story but yeah I feel like the strengths
of a movie would work good with how I'd
like to tell that story
why haven't you quit on this script
because I want to be a screenwriter
honestly I mean I don't see anything
else in life that I really want to do I
mean through more it's may sound stupid
but through marching band and like being
a drum major I learned a lot about like
what perseverance really means you know
and
I'll leave that at that but you know why
that never really seemed like an option
to me stop but
what do you write okay so the current
screenplay that I'm running around now
is about a college student freshman you
know outcast most of his life that type
of story and he meets a girl and you
know the story is like it's like the
slow passage of time from the beginning
of their relationship to the end and
like all the craziness that ensues
because the girl he falls in love with
is a cannibal right so the premise is
well like what I was going for is like
who was it son soon I believe in correct
me if I'm wrong but son to ask the
question if your father steals like some
bread or something from a market what do
you do some would say the right answer
is to turn them in and then Santa would
reply if it isn't so well have you no
loyalty to your family you know and I
like to like touch on that when it comes
to like you know something a lot deeper
like if your son was a murderer or if
your if your girlfriend or your lover
was accountable um and don't worry you
know you you'll I'll explain a lot more
to you but in terms of just the story is
about a boy who finds solace with a
woman or a girl and she turns out to be
accountable
running low on time here
what are your screenwriting goals while
all of my screenplays will that I'm
writing I definitely intend them to be
filmed you know but I'd understand if
they didn't make it but I guess at its
core I just want recognition and
criticism because I feel like I'm ready
to pursue this full-time I mean I'm
going in school yeah but I'm ready to
pursue this full-time oh my screen
writing career not much to tell you
Deanna month ago honestly but thank you
for your consideration film courage I've
been a subscriber for a while and I
intend to stick with you for as long as
I can thank you